it's Groundhog Day actually it's 12th
night but it feels like Groundhog Day
because yesterday for the second day in
a row Republican Congressional leader
Kevin McCarthy lost another three votes
now I'm not saying three individual I'm
saying they took a vote three times and
he lost all of them again to become
Speaker of the House of Representatives
after 20 conservatives voted against him
depriving McCarthy of the 218 votes that
he needs the establishment is whining
and crying as their preferred speaker
candidate cannot seem to get over the
finish line but the conservative
stalwarts have every right to spike
McCarthy for any reason they choose
policy trust because they just don't
like the cut of his jib doesn't matter
the job of the house speaker is to
Wrangle cats basically through a
combination of Love fear and persuasion
the speaker of the house needs to create
consensus among his members the speaker
vote is the first test of a would-be
Leader's ability to do that and if the
man can't get the votes then he just
can't get the votes I'm Michael Knowles
it's the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from Noah Lin who
says somebody should have just told
Antigone that her brother wasn't getting
desecrated by being left in the field to
rot he was being human composted and
that's okay could have saved her a lot
of heartache and sophocally is a lot of
writing such a great perceptive comment
so true we could lose so much
of uh of our tragedy of our sense of
morality and human dignity if if we just
accept the libs uh tossing granny out
into the garden to turn into worm food
you're so right you make such a good
point speaking of nature when you when
you want your body feeling really really
good you've got to check out balance of
nature right now go to
balanceofnature.com use promo code at
Knowles it can be difficult to live a
healthy life that is why I love balance
of nature balance of nature fruits and
veggies are the best way to make sure
you are getting essential nutritional
ingredients every single day their
products are 100 percent whole food is a
really important aspect balance of
nature uses a cold vacuum process that
preserves the natural phytonutrients in
whole fruits and vegetables and
encapsulates them for easy consumption
balance of nature sent a bunch of their
products down to the office for our team
to try
the team absolutely loved them the
hyenas here at Daily wire always grab
them up before I have to reach out to
grab my last bag when you are
disciplined enough to take care of your
health you reap all kinds of benefits
more energy less fatigue better focus
consuming the right balance of fruits
and veggies every day is an important
First Step go to balanceofnature.com use
promo code Knolls kwles for 25 off your
first order as a preferred customer plus
a free fiber and spice that is
balanceofnature.com promo code
knowlescana w l e s for 25 off your
first preferred order
the balance of power now not just in the
House of Representatives but within the
GOP within the House of Representatives
is a little bit upset and people are
getting very very angry about this and
especially the GOP establishment is
furious this is getting nasty this is
getting personal
typified perfectly by an interview last
night between Lauren bobert who is one
of the congressmen leading the charge
against Kevin McCarthy in the house and
Sean Hannity who spent much of his TV
show last night
promoting Kevin McCarthy and attacking
the conservatives who don't want
McCarthy to be speaker
listen to this Exchange
let me turn the tables congresswoman
Kevin McCarthy is 202 three votes your
site has 20. so if I'm going to use your
words and your methodology and your math
uh is it a time for you to pack it in in
your side to pack it in considering he
has over 200 and you have 20.
Sean I understand the frustration I
promise you but I'm not frustrated you
didn't answer my question we are hearing
we are hearing from you who are still
voting with Kevin McCarthy do not
answering my question of what we're
doing and they're cheering us on so
there are more for us than are against
us and they are waiting for Kevin to
keep
um
certainly frustrated by I'm frustrated
by you not answering a direct question
you said to president Trump you you said
earlier today that President Trump needs
to tell Kevin McCarthy you don't have
the votes can I finish candidate to
elect it can I finish the house you
don't have the votes and it's time to
withdraw he has 203 your side has 20.
why is it time for him to withdraw and
not you when he has so many more votes
well Sean he needs 218 and he does not
have 218. we've been trying
Lauren's right oh my goodness gracious I
don't know Sean Hannity personally so I
don't I've got nothing against him
personally and I am friends with Lauren
but Sean is just completely missing the
point here
he's saying well Kevin McCarthy's got
200 you've only got 20. so why don't you
drop it because Lauren bobert isn't
running for Speaker of the House
Matt Gates is not running for Speaker of
the House neither of them have suggested
that they want the job it's not up to
them to come up with 200 votes to to
become speaker of the house it's up to
Kevin McCarthy as the would-be speaker
as the leader of the Republican
conference in the house to get the
number of votes that he needs if he
can't get the number of votes that he
needs then he's a weak leader that's
that okay it's not it's not all that
complicated I I can't tell
if if Hannity was being obtuse or if
he's actually missing the point here
but the point is
being speaker is a very difficult job
being a leader of either Party in the
House of Representatives but especially
of the Republicans where there are much
there's a far greater variety of
perspectives than in the Democrats who
are pretty much all locked up on the
Progressive side among the Republicans
you got the moderates you got the
Libertarians you got the traditionalists
you got the populist she got this that
and the other thing it's a difficult job
and if you want to be speaker you've got
to get at the bare minimum the
sufficient number of votes to become the
speaker
if Kevin McCarthy does not have the
votes that's not Lauren bobert's fault
that's not Matt Gates's fault that's not
Paul gosar's fault
it just means that McCarthy
couldn't get it over the Finish Line as
I mentioned yesterday this is exactly
what happened the last time McCarthy was
up for the job
the last time McCarthy was up for it is
2015 John Boehner was stepping down as
Speaker McCarthy was The Heir Apparent
and he couldn't get the votes
and so there was a compromise candidate
in Paul Ryan who now he seems much
squishier than he did then at the time
he was considered one of the more
conservative members of the house and
Paul Ryan was acceptable both to The
Establishment and to the house Freedom
caucus and so he became the speaker
it is not even a particular knock on
McCarthy's Integrity or his beliefs or
anything like that but it just means
that McCarthy was not able to muster the
love fear deal making whatever you need
to get the votes okay and so Sean
Hannity can yell about it and and
interrogate Lauren bobert all night and
cut her off and and try to bully her
into to giving up the fight but the fact
is Kevin McCarthy was not born with an
entitlement to become the Speaker of the
House
you you have to earn that job through
deal making through intimidating your
colleagues through inspiring love among
your colleagues and he just hasn't done
it John Boehner was able to do it Paul
Ryan was able to do it I'm not saying
there's even any alternative now who's
able to do it better than McCarthy but
that's no excuse okay the buck stops
with the leader the leader has not been
able to do it and so the establishment
they're not just calling on the Sean
hannities of the world to go out there
and Bully the house Freedom caucus
they're calling on Donald Trump and
Lauren this is going to be the Lauren
bobert show today I actually texted
Lauren last night when this was all
blowing up and I said hey I know you're
a little busy you got other things to do
right now but if you're free tomorrow
morning and you don't have to be on the
floor of the House of Representatives to
to lead this fight would love for you to
come on the show so I think she actually
might be able to come on the show
depending on when these votes are taking
place today obviously stay tuned we'll
keep you posted but in the meantime
Lauren called out even Donald Trump for
supporting McCarthy and trying to bully
the freedom caucus
so let's work together let's stop with
the campaign smears and tactics to get
people to turn against us
even having my favorite President call
us and tell us we need to knock this off
I think it actually needs to be reversed
the president needs to tell Kevin
McCarthy that sir you do not have the
votes and it's time to withdraw
with that I yield thank you it's a
simple enough argument and and what I'm
hearing from The Establishment right now
is basically but it's not fair it was
supposed to be Kevin you guys only have
20 votes yeah 20 votes is enough how do
you think this works goodness gracious
me
there was then
some fake news that was spread yesterday
which is that it was a truth social post
or a
save America make America great again
sort of letterhead that said I Donald
Trump and pulling my support from Kevin
McCarthy it was a forgery Trump has
disavowed that post going around
but it add even more to the confusion of
this political fight there's an irony of
this fight too
which is that
strictly from the standpoint of issues
strictly from the standpoint of policy
positions
Kevin McCarthy would very likely be the
most conservative speaker of the house
that we have had since Joe Martin in
1954.
he would from the strictly the
standpoint you just look down the list
of issues abortion immigration
trade whatever you look down the list of
issues
he on the whole of Kevin McCarthy's
career again he hasn't been tested as a
speaker of the house but on the hold of
McCarthy's career you just look on his
votes you look at his policy positions
he certainly lands to the right of John
Boehner I think he lands to the right of
Paul Ryan frankly he lands to the right
of Newt Gingrich
because Newt Gingrich though a great
conservative fighter
Newt Gingrich said during the partial
birth abortion fight that he would
campaign for Republicans who supported
partial birth abortion he he tried to
Lobby against an RNC provision that
would defund Republican candidates who
were in favor of partial birth abortion
he sat down with Nancy Pelosi and
promoted a bunch of climate change stuff
so again none of this is a knock on Newt
Gingrich I really like Newt Gingrich I'm
just saying strictly from the standpoint
of issues
Kevin McCarthy is I think to the right
of any of them in recent history there
just haven't been that many republican
speakers of the house in the last half
century or more
but
leadership races are not just about
issues
frankly I'm not sure they're even
primarily about issues when you elect
your Congressman you were electing him
on issues because his job is to cast a
vote on policy
when you vote when the members of
Congress vote for a speaker
it's about a lot more than that it's
about coalitions it's about truck do you
trust this person do you think this
person will keep his promises has he
sided with you before it's kind of like
high school what click is he a part of
what what lunch table does he sit at who
is he giving money to in the campaign
years who is he defunding in the
campaign years is he loyal when the
going gets tough can he be counted on to
stand firm and the simple fact is there
are 20 members of the House of
Representatives who are on the more
conservative side of the GOP who are
members of the freedom caucus who just
don't think that Kevin McCarthy is the
man for the job
and you might say well those members
they're terrible they're wrong they're
imprudent they're crazy they're
showboating they're whatever I don't
want to hear the excuses what you need
in a leader is leadership okay that is
the primary quality that you need in a
leader so if McCarthy can can grab the
votes good on him I guess he passed his
first test if he can't then he probably
was not going to be a very good a very
good or effective speaker in the first
place
when you want to better yourself not
just in a political sense but in an
eternal sense you've got to check out
father Mike schmitz's Bible in a year
podcast right now go to
ascensionpress.com Knowles if you're
someone who has always wanted to read
and understand the Bible but you're not
sure where to start then check out the
Bible in a year podcast from Ascension
the Bible linear podcast is currently
the most popular religion podcast in the
United States millions of people have
listened to it and twice it has hit the
number one spot on Apple podcasts it is
the only podcast that I reliably Listen
to I've taken a little bit slower you
know so you can take it to round Pace
too might end up being the Bible in two
years but in the Bible into your father
Mike Schmitz reads the entire Bible in
365 daily episodes provides helpful
commentary reflection and prayer along
the way what better way to start the new
year you can find the Bible and ear
podcast with father Mike Schmitz for
free in your favorite podcast app or on
YouTube plus you can follow along with a
special reading plan to help you better
understand the story unlike like any
other Bible podcast
Bible in a year follows this special
plan that organizes the books of the
Bible in a way that helps listeners
understand the story get it at
ascensionpress.com Knowles if you want
to start reading and more importantly
understanding the Bible this year you go
to ascensionpress.com Knowles download
the Bible reading plan for free
ascensionpress.com Knowles to download
that plan for free one of my favorite
exchanges that took place at the Capitol
yesterday was from uh Republican
Congressman Kat kamek who got up and she
said listen fellas the Democrats they
want to see us fighting with each other
that's why they're over there indulging
in all sorts of vices and enjoying
themselves they want us divided they
want us to fight each other that much
has been made clear by the popcorn and
blankets and alcohol that is coming over
there
[Music]
the house is not in order
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
the house is not in order
[Applause]
[Applause]
the clerk would ask all members elect to
abide by the established decorum of the
house while making nominations
it goes on a cat cab mix they were just
laughing just laughing away you know
these Democrats everything with their
booze and their popcorn in there
I loved this clip and I love the
Democrats getting all angry about it and
clutching their pearls because it made
me think that
Republicans we don't want to be like
that we don't want to be like the
Democrats clutching their pearls all
Angry red in the face all the time I
think cat kamek's attitude is is far
better
it's okay guys it's all right this is
democracy in action
you can laugh a little bit the world is
not going to end if Kevin McCarthy
doesn't become the speaker of the house
within the next 15 minutes okay it'll be
just fine
you like democracy this is what
democracy is
you like legislative bodies in
Washington DC probably you don't like
those things
because the legislative bodies in
Washington DC are also known as the
Swamp they don't have the best
reputation in the world but
I think I saw some poll that Congress
was less popular than syphilis for
different periods of American history
but nevertheless this is what we've got
this is the system of government this is
how it works they're all big boys Kevin
McCarthy's got plenty of thick skin it's
okay let it play out this this is
democracy in action if you if you can't
get a kick out of this sort of thing
get another job if you work in politics
and if you can't get a kick out of this
kind of thing get another system of
government because this is what
democracy is speaking of the house
Democrats the house Democrats now
while Republicans are fighting over who
the leader should be the house Democrats
they've got him now
you know the hymn I'm talking about
they're Trump
they finally got him
that Roadrunner Donald Trump he has
evaded
Wiley Coyote democrats for about seven
eight years now
but they finally went to Acme
they bought the biggest Anvil they can
find they've got him now
they're releasing his tax returns
didn't they already do that didn't we
already get Trump's tax returns didn't
didn't My Doppelganger over at MSNBC
Rachel Maddow already read them on air
and find out there was really nothing
particularly interesting or lurid in
them
I guess but now the house of Democrats
they've got more of his tax returns yeah
that'll show him and
what did they find pretty much nothing
they got about 6 000 pages of
information on how Trump handles his
taxes
and they found out this is going to
shock you Donald Trump
takes tax deductions to reduce the
amount that he has to pay the government
every year
and he tries to minimize
in his accounting The Profit that his
company makes to reduce his tax burden
and he
that's it he just does what every
businessman has done ever
no evidence of any crimes of course
is nothing they've got nothing as
they've always had nothing from the
beginning and they're going to try again
and I'm sure they're going to drag this
issue out for another 10 years Donald
Trump is going to have been in the grave
for half a century they're going to
they're still going to be trying to get
him improved collusion and tax crimes
and all the rest of it the reason that
this matters though
is it's a real stain on the Congress and
it's a real stain on the Ways and Means
Committee and the Democrats are as
stained as they can possibly be but it
is a real stain on them because there
was no legal reason
to release Donald Trump's taxes
it doesn't matter it doesn't have much
of a political consequence to him
but
citizens have an expectation when we
file our taxes
that the government is not just going to
release them whenever we become
political targets
and that's what the government has done
here
if there were some pressing National
Security public interest reason to
release Donald Trump's tax returns
then maybe there's an argument to do it
but there wasn't here it was just a
completely arbitrary exercise in power
and it means for every citizen of the
United States
certainly for every conservative
certainly for every prominent
conservative but really for every other
citizen who might imagine that at some
point the the other party is going to
get into power
you now think when you're filing your
taxes oh this could just be totally
public information
because the trust whatever trust we once
had with the federal government that is
evaporating by the very day speaking of
corrupt Democrats
Katie Hobbs has been sworn in as the
governor of Arizona Kerry Lake as far as
I know has still not conceded that
Arizona governor's race with good reason
there was a lot of crooked stuff that
appeared to go on in Arizona in the 2022
elections
election machines magically not working
vote counts taking a very long time to
come in precincts reporting hundreds
more votes by the end of the day than
voters who were checked in to vote at
that Precinct a lot of dodginess the
person who was in charge of the
elections this past cycle coincidentally
was Katie Hobbs then the Arizona
Secretary of State now sworn in as
governor of Arizona
as Katie Hobbs was sworn in
she was asked to defend the Constitution
I kid you not
she started laughing when she was asked
to do that
to solemnly swear
that I will support the Constitution
I will support the Constitution of the
United States of the United States and
the Constitution and laws and the
constitution in laws of the State of
Arizona of the State of Arizona I
solemnly
swear that I will uphold
the Constitution oh stop it hahaha not a
good look lady I don't know exactly why
she was laughing I hope that there was
some explanation as to why she was
laughing at the prospect of her
upholding the Constitution but it's
definitely not a good look and
the reason that I'm a little reluctant
to just write it off and say oh well
it's probably just a coincidence is
because the whole swearing-in was not a
great look Katie Hobbs did not allow the
press to cover her swearing in
she allowed I think one photographer
from the Associated Press into the room
at the state capitol while she told the
rest of the press to just watch it on a
screen somewhere
which is in keeping with Katie hobbs's
campaign were lack thereof Katie Hopps
barely campaigned for the race which I
think lends a lot of credibility to the
suggestion that the fix was in that this
was a a
somewhat questionable election process
especially when you add on to it the
fact that Katie Hobbs was the official
in charge of running the elections when
you add on to it the fact that the
election officials in Maricopa County
where all the shenanigans occurred even
the ones who were nominally Republicans
were openly campaigning against
candidates like Kerry Lake the whole
thing just seems really dodgy and
sketchy the whole thing does not seem
particularly Democratic are we allowed
to suggest that I don't want to I know
that we're one day away from the most
sacred Feast of the liberal liturgical
year
January 6 the great solemnity of January
6th according to the libs and we're
never allowed to question the sacredness
of our democracy unless it's convenient
for the Democrats but I don't know
what's been going going on in Arizona
doesn't look particularly Democratic to
me it's a new year
but leftist companies are still up to
their same old dirty tricks ladies it is
time to help your fellas wash out the
woke once and for all with Jeremy's
Razor's new line of men's Staples he
will love the tea tree and argon oil
infused shampoo and conditioner
exfoliating charcoal body wash or if
he's a soap traditionalist who prefers
something to hold on to the oatmeal and
citrus soap scrub wow that sounds good
they smell great they're all made right
here in the USA by a Men's Grooming
company that does not hate men I use
Jeremy's razors shower products every
single day okay this quaff this quaff
that you all love so much brought to you
by Jeremy's razors when you visit the
store do it through my URL so that I get
the referral bragging rights and because
I think I am most benefiting from it the
company was started because Harry's
Razors was boycotting me because I said
men are women and uh the the products
are are being used I think by me more
than any other host so head on over to
dailywire.com Knowles treat your man to
some great Jeremy's razors products
today dailywire.com Knowles
speaking of abuses of power
my colleague Jordan Peterson
is being investigated by the Ontario
College of psychologists
and he's being investigated by them he's
being threatened by them
they are suggesting that they might
take away his license to practice
psychology
because Jordan
tweeted against political correctness
basically he announced the other day
that the Ontario College of psychologist
has demanded that he submit himself to
mandatory Social Media communication
retraining
and with their experts for among other
crimes retweeting the Canadian
conservative leader and criticizing
Justin Trudeau the big lib who's running
Canada and some people are saying the
son of Fidel Castro I would never
suggest such a thing uh because he did
that because Jordan has tweeted and
supported the conservatives against the
Liberals they want him to be re-educated
they want to send him to a re-education
camp or
he says he will face an in-person
tribunal and suspension of his right to
operate as a licensed clinical
psychologist
Preposterous of course now they're not
going to destroy Jordan Peterson's
career Jordan Peterson will be just fine
he's not going to starve if they take
away his license to practice psychology
but on people who don't have
multi-million best-selling books and
world tours and shows and movies and all
the rest of it
this kind of power the power of
credentialism could destroy somebody's
life and career
some of you maybe many of you listening
to this show today
have very possibly faced this kind of
question especially during covid
even even outside of covid though if you
don't say the right thing if you don't
do the right thing then you're going to
be blackballed from your job then the
licensing or credentialing organization
they're not going to give you your
license then the university is not going
to give you what has become the basic
credential of operating in our our
liberal culture you need to have the
four-year college degree what do you
need to have learned nothing what what
skills you need to have acquired
absolutely none but you need to have
that credential or you're not allowed to
be admitted to the very special club to
work in all the fancy jobs in our
culture
it's a problem of credentialism now
it this underlines A movement that you
have seen for a long time on the
American right
which is that we have every day that
passes less and less respect for these
kinds of credentials this was not always
the case this is actually a trend that
is going on and people call it populism
and people call it anti-intellectualism
it it's not that
it's not our fault it's not the
conservative's fault it is the fault of
the people who Dole out the credentials
for squandering their own credibility
it's not not my fault that a Harvard
degree or Yale degree or a Stanford
degree
doesn't mean what it used to mean
50 70 years ago the New York Times used
to report on the outcomes of Yale
political union undergraduate debates
today
at the Yale political union and similar
sorts of debating societies students
will whine and cry and throw a hissy fit
if Kristen Wagoner a pro-life
pro-religious Freedom lawyer shows up
and explains the law in fact actually I
want to be fair it wasn't the Yale
political union where that incident
occurred it was at the Yale law school
this was graduate students this was the
professional students who were supposed
to be lawyers whining crying basically
throwing a riot because someone has a
different opinion it's not the fault of
the conservatives now who mock all of
the elite credentials
it's the fault of the elite institutions
which have squandered all of their own
credibility
and I I right now we're at this this
difficult point where
people are getting squeezed because the
credentials still kind of matter there
is still some power in them but people
know it's all kind of hollow and bogus
but it still sort of matters I very much
look forward to the day
where
a psychologist will not need the
approval of the Ontario College of
psychologists
who are who are have revealed themselves
to be nothing more than a leftist
activist organization to practice
psychology
or of of any of these other gatekeeping
institutions that have been totally
captured by the left that have that have
crawled in like Invasion of the Body
Snatchers hollowed out the guts of what
these institutions used to be and now
they're walking around
pretending that they still have
authority they don't we the only way out
is through there's no going back to
those good old days okay you the the
only way that you're going to achieve
good old days from good new days rather
is by by pushing through and saying
screw it who cares who cares what the
Ontario College is like if I want to
talk to Jordan Peterson and have him try
to fix my brain I'm going to do it
whether the Ontario College of
psychologist wants to or not and and the
Canadian government wants to come after
him for doing that well maybe it's time
that we have a little less respect for
the Canadian government and all of these
other
liberal totalitarians who who want to
who want to banish any sense of reason
and tradition and normal life from our
society speaking of titles and
credentials
I I need you all to take out your violin
cases the tiniest little violin case
you've got open those tiny little
latches pull out that little miniature
instrument and start playing the SOB
song for Prince Harry who is very he's
very upset he's very hurt
Prince Harry who has spent the last
several years
attacking his family in the most Public
public way possible as his grandfather
and grandmother are dying two of the
most respected people on the world stage
he's just lambasting his family whining
woe is me he says he wants privacy and
then he just keeps going on TV all the
time well now he's whining because
apparently his family isn't being very
nice to him
it never needed to be this way the
leaking and the planting I want a family
not an institution they feel as though
it's better to keep us somehow as the
villains they've shown absolutely no
willingness to reconcile I would like to
get my father back I would like to have
my brother back
this is so toddry
this is just so it shows you how
dishonest and disingenuous the whole
Megan Harry phenomenon has been
because what they say is we don't want
to be in the spotlight anymore we don't
the Press has been so we hate the press
the Press has been so unfair we had to
leave England because of how how we're
in the press all the time and so what
are we going to do the very first thing
we do in our private lives
we launch a TV show we give an interview
to Oprah we give an interview to the
guardian we write books we sell those
books on TV we do it's just it's so
tawdry and dishonest and it it reminds
you that when you want
if if things just continually are going
wrong in your life
over everyone's going to experience
tough times that's not necessarily your
fault but if things are just
consistently if everything is constantly
wrong in your life
maybe you don't cast the blame on
grandma or grandpa or daddy or brother
or that maybe the person to look at is
that guy staring back at you in the
mirror and maybe the what you ought to
do is not just seek attention everywhere
from the whole public maybe it's time to
look Inward and see
if you can fix something about yourself
this would be a lesson that our friends
over in the GOP might be able to figure
out the sort of people who have
empowered in the GOP for a very long
time might might be able to figure out
if they had an ounce of self-awareness
but they don't so instead they're
blaming Lauren bobert we have Lauren on
the call Lauren thank you so much I know
you're very very busy right now but
thank you for making time to come on the
show
absolutely thanks so much for having me
on Michael so Lauren where does it all
stand we've given a recap of of the the
speaker fight through last night on the
show Kevin McCarthy lost three rounds of
voting two days ago he loses three runs
of voting yesterday you and those
terrible evil House Freedom caucus
Republicans you're you're not budging
here so what happens
well let's begin at where it started
this started in the summer we wanted to
handle this privately
um and and have a solution before
January 3rd these negotiations began in
the summer and they were dismissed
because Kevin McCarthy thought he was
going to have this massive Red Wave and
our votes did not matter when he saw
that the 300 million dollars that he
raised did not produce the red wave that
he promised he realized quickly he's
going to need our votes and so some
concessions
um were were put into play it was very
difficult to get them into play it was
difficult to get them approved with our
rules process the Way Washington D.C
operates and functions we want to
fundamentally change this town it is
broken it is less popular with the
American people than cockroaches so we
have to get something right here and we
cannot go along with the status quo well
on January 2nd um two of my fellow
colleagues and myself Matt Gates Scott
Perry we walked into
leader McCarthy's office after whipping
votes all day long and handed him 218
votes we said here it is let's seal the
deal here's some common sense issues
that you can put forward some promises
that you can make single member motion
to vacate so there is accountability on
the third in line to the presidency of
the United States you cannot demand more
responsibility and follow Nancy Pelosi's
precedence of less accountability so
this is our check and balance on the
speaker and that was a priority for me
personally certainly and for many others
but then things like bring the Texas
border plan to the floor for a vote
bring a term limits Bill to the floor
for a vote any member who wants to
reduce spending in an amendment will
make that amendment in order so we can
bring it to the floor and have a vote
earmarks bring them to the floor
individually for a vote this is spending
money that we do not have so let's at
least have a vote on it instead of
packing it into a bill where we'd have
no option to either swallow the whole
thing or say no way
um these are things that we presented to
him he uh solicited a list from us of
committee assignments all members
provide committee assignment requests we
know where our talents and skills are
are best utilized and we provided that
list Kevin McCarthy made a great
argument saying listen the people in
this group only want two committees I
need you spread out I want you to have
more influence and we agreed with that
and we said you know this is a time
constraint on many of the members that's
a lot of responsibility a lot of
pressure but we're willing to take that
sacrifice and have these committee
assignments that bear more pressure and
so we've provided that to him and then
January 2nd when all of that was laid on
the table
Kevin McCarthy laughed us out of the
room said that it was a selfish wish
wish list and would not take the deal
well now here we stand Michael I no
longer have those 218 votes to provide
to Kevin McCarthy so it doesn't matter
if I go to the floor today and vote for
Kevin McCarthy because there are now
more than ever votes that he does not
have to get to that speakership this is
very important to know he walked out of
that meeting and lied about what we
requested trust is absolutely broken if
there were if there was any to begin
with and this is a huge problem we want
unity in the Republican party and I
believe now is the time to start
seriously considering consensus
candidates who will unify the Republican
party so we can get to work for the
American people this is really important
context I think because what you're
saying is over the summer leader
McCarthy just didn't think he needed you
guys because there there were supposed
to be more Republicans in the house and
so he would be able to win the
speakership without having your votes
along
because of what happened that turned out
to be a Bad Bet and when you make bad
bets you got to pay the price for those
bad bets and and you bring up this other
point which is trust and I think this is
really important because a lot of this
debate has focused on how on the issues
Kevin McCarthy is relatively pretty good
you know we come from a world of John
Boehner's so I guess Kevin McCarthy is
more conservative than John Boehner but
but what you're saying is no it's really
about trust when we're talking about
leadership elections we need to be able
to trust the leader and and what you're
saying is you don't think that leader
McCarthy has proven himself trustworthy
correct and that's why we wanted the
tools implemented
um to where maybe we don't need to trust
him because the individual member is
empowered enough to get the job done and
is not ruled by a dictator as a speaker
um this is not a kingdom that we live in
we don't anoint a king I believe that
this is how our founding fathers
intended this process to work our vote
is there to be debated not just rubber
stamped and cast to the biggest
fundraiser but you cannot have good
faith negotiations where trust is absent
and so that's why motion to vacate was
so important to me because that is the
check and balance on this position if
you break trust if you don't do what you
promised well buddy you're out of there
and he has already shown he's not
willing to do that I still have not seen
a public announcement of a single member
motion to vacate he's lying to me for
those listening who don't know what that
is what is emotion today take it
a motion to vacate gives us the
opportunity to remove the speaker and
have another vote for speaker if
necessary this is something that does
not get used but it's available this is
something Thomas and Thomas Jefferson
um wrote and has been in effect for
nearly two centuries and Nancy Pelosi
was the first speaker in history to
modify that she removed that individual
empowerment from the from the member and
uh and said you no longer have a say in
this I get to rule how I want and you
don't have a check you don't have a
balance Kevin McCarthy wanted to leave
that as Nancy Pelosi had it there were
concessions he got down to 50 got down
to 20 got down to five no Thomas
Jefferson wrote it as one member any one
member can bring that motion to vacate
the chair forward and that is our
accountability this is something that
was my red line and I've only heard from
a staff member who chased us out of the
GOP conference and begged us to vote for
Kevin McCarthy we'll give you single
member motion to vacate and I said
that's adorable where's Kevin saying it
so so I guess this is now where the
rubber meets the road and I know you're
short on time so
what happens after all of this context I
mean I think you've explained your
position very very well I think that
it's it is pretty clear that leader
McCarthy he just he thought he had the
votes and he didn't have the votes and
and this actually the same thing
happened in 2015 let's not forget Kevin
McCarthy was The Heir Apparent after
John Boehner he didn't have the votes
and that's how Paul Ryan emerged as the
compromise candidate so so what happens
what could Kevin McCarthy come out and
say right now that would win over your
votes and maybe the votes of your
colleagues in the freedom caucus or
if there's nothing that he could say
who who would you support today I know
that this is a little bit in flux but
who would you support today to replace
him
right so we have been offering a menu of
other candidates
um I I don't believe that my my
switching to Kevin McCarthy matters
because there are so many who are
solidly Kevin you can issue in a public
apology you can change all the rules you
can wear a straight jacket and and just
have a portrait that says that your
speaker and we get to run this place and
they're not going to vote for Kevin
McCarthy so at this point we do have to
start looking forward
um to other other candidates and I can
name 200 who are potential candidates
right out of the conference GOP I'm
excluding myself so that's why that
number is 200 and Kevin's excluded as
well
um but you know this this is something
that we have to start talking about
we've presented
um Jim Jordan's Jim Jordan we have
presented Andy Biggs we've presented
Byron Donald's I've heard Jim Banks name
be voted on in in these during these
votes maybe it's someone outside of
Congress maybe it's a Lee zeldin who
actually won US the majority without his
efforts in New York running for governor
we wouldn't have the majority and maybe
it's it's someone who is in the
conference like a Kevin Hearn who is
currently chairman of the Republican
study committee which is the largest
caucus in the Republican conference he
was unanimously elected with 173 votes
to chair that committee and he actually
has a balanced budget that he wants to
put on the floor which is another thing
that Kevin denied in our proposal on
January 2nd so maybe it's someone like
that who already has the trust of the
conference and can truly get to 218.
Before I Let You Go Lauren
is is the trust now just irreparably
broken that is to say if Kevin McCarthy
came out and issued a statement said
okay I'll give you a single member
motion to vacate okay I'll give you this
that or the other thing one would that
change your vote and two
would that change enough votes to to put
him into the speakership I know you've
suggested maybe not but but just to be
totally clear are you saying that
from the people you're talking to
McCarthy's speaker candidacy is is
actually dead
it's dead yes the nails are in the
coffin and uh there are plenty of
members who are cheering our efforts on
who are afraid of Retribution
um we were threatened in conference it
was it was a nightmare in there we were
threatened
um by steering
um committee members who who actually
assign committees to members of Congress
that um if we vote against Kevin at all
we will not receive committee
assignments and Kevin McCarthy affirmed
that he stood up and said your District
elects you your conference elects what
committee you are assigned to
um and so trust is broken as it stands
for me I am a no on Kevin and there are
too many others who are there uh who
don't allow him to get to 218 he doesn't
have the numbers Michael
wow that's that's really really big and
I have to tell you I know that people
are pulling their hair out over this
especially in the establishment GOP
to me this is positive it's a
constitutional republic at work this is
it this is kind of how it works and if
you're going to make bets in politics
then you got to make sure those bets pay
off or you're going to pay the price and
if you if you want a leadership role I
know you recently had an interview on
television where where the host who will
remain unnamed was yelling because he
said well Kevin McCarthy has 200 votes
you only have 20 votes well I thought
you made the point very well the first
test of a congressional leader someone
who is in leadership someone who's The
Speaker of the House is
can you get the votes that it takes to
put you into the office because the
whole job is getting the votes and
creating consensus Lauren thank you so
much for taking the time today I will be
waiting with popcorn maybe with some
booze as cat kamek suggested people do
to to see how this fight uh plays out
thank you for coming on thank you so
much and I do believe that history is
going to show that we are on the right
side of this we're going to get it right
all right thank you Lauren that's it
I've run out of time I'm Michael olsis
the Michael Knowles show we are heading
over to the member block right now so do
not go anywhere unless you're not a
daily wire member then you've got to
head on over to dailywire.com right now
subscribe become a member we'll see you
over at the member block
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]